that's every marvel cup the baseball we
won't be able to be spotted we were a
baseball game
no clark bucky's got the cap
that's bucky
hello there reject nation we got
ourselves
a final trailer for falcon and winter
soldier
amazon
24-hour delivery that actually took 72
hours wow
amazon bezos yeah you're slacking on me
bezos anyways if you guys didn't catch
the interview that we did with the
director of the falcon winter soldier
kari skoglund make sure to check it out
it's a blast of an interview and all
your comments have been so
nice thank you guys anywho let's see
what's in store
without ruining anything that we know of
which isn't really a whole lot
that's our first episode yeah that's why
they only gave us one
yeah it feels like it belongs to someone
else
yeah yo that show represents a lot of
things to a lot of people
[Music]
symbols are nothing without the women
and men that give them meaning
that is true we need someone
to inspire us again
[Applause]
the world's more complicated now
you're never going to stop
this world issue yeah this looks like
the movie heather
wow oh it doesn't have to be a war
it already is
truly michael mann vibes about this for
some reason to me right now
we're gonna do it our own way
[Music]
not necessarily a team
[Music]
we look damn good though
america's asses tune in
guys tune in so much of this trailer
was honing in on the themes that i feel
like
are maybe not strongly clicking with
audiences as much as i hope they are in
the marketing i'm talking about
because it's so easy to get so wrapped
up in only the action
and like the exciting stuff because it
is it is it's exciting it really is it's
all there yeah
yeah but but the thing is there's such
rich storytelling in here from just us
watching the first episode alone
and what they were talking about you
know like most of this obviously we
haven't seen
like 99 percent of this
but the thing is is like when they're
talking immediately about that shield
means a lot of different things to it's
like a lot of different people
and how sam is saying symbols are
nothing without the women and men that
give them
meaning and one thing that the director
was talking with us about
is about the symbolism of the shield
itself and what does that mean
for specifically sam wilson a black man
to take up
the shield to carry the red white and
blue in the kind of world that we live
in and this world deals so much
with post blip and how i feel like they
released it in the press release about
the some of the villainous angles about
it so i don't feel like it's something
i'm revealing here
it's something they have volunteered but
just to be safe i'll cut back some of my
words a little bit with its antagonists
that they're presenting
there's a divide with the world because
some people like the way some things
were when everyone was gone
and they're not happy with post blip and
so having that divide and these two lead
characters
in association with each other because
of their connection to captain america
and them having to work together and
find their own way by following in the
inspiration they've had and influence
from cap
but learning how to not just live within
his shadow specifically
you know learning to live his values in
a way that just
exemplifies what he stood for and that
you know
spreads that around and you know
bolsters it for the future
and i feel like that's all here in this
trailer absolutely and it's weird like
going back to the other trailers
and being like oh it is there yeah just
get so caught up in like how cool
everything looks that i'm not
really picking up on the deeper stuff
yeah yeah well i mean this one had had
sort of like all the voiceovers geared
towards like the general themes and
stuff like that and you know then you
had a lot of the action-packed stuff in
the visuals but
it does really this as of this trailer
at least feel a bit darker and a bit
edgier in a way not edgy and like a ah
cool bro
but you know like it does sort of feel
like a michael mann movie or something
like that of a different calendar
epic yeah yeah you're gonna see
all your big spectacular actions
synthesized through something that
is hopefully a little more
thought-provoking and a little more
intense yeah you know than just sci-fi
circumstances and yeah i feel like the
blend that that's going to present is
great and i love
that you know throughout this they are
honing further and further in
on the people yeah that wear these
symbols and what
the personal relationship for them is to
the rest of the world right
not just the other way around the
position these two guys are into is
interesting because
you know bucky's on like a super
redemptive path and sam
is just trying to find his place without
you know his his best bud and you know
the
real guy he looked up to well bucky's on
not only a redemptive path but
the one time he was able to be on his
own post being winter soldier
he was still a fugitive yeah you know
and like all throughout civil war like
the life that he's been living he's been
having to live in in marvel undercover
baseball cap this is his first time he
gets to live
just in the real world he just gets to
live in the real world and be a civilian
and like how do you be just be a
civilian yeah
yeah and to that tune also i feel like
this trailer also hones in on how it
really does at least
it's giving me the sense that this is
two guys
against a huge situation with a lot of
moving parts yeah
like it really does feel like you're
alone with them for a bumpy ride
but a fun ride oh yeah i think this is
going to be like
one surprisingly inspirational show like
what's cool about the cinematography
from this trailer is it just looks like
the visual
palais is going to change a lot
already i've said this several times
best falcon action
we've ever seen and then there's more
stuff here i'm like oh man this just
keeps getting better this is
like there's something there's so much
creativity with
the falcon and the way they'd
choreograph his fight scenes
specifically him
like bucky is all the great stuff that
we've seen him do you know and i'm sure
we'll get some new stuff but
bucky has pretty much always been
awesome to watch um
and then here with falconer like this is
this is like the version of falcon we've
been waiting for but i feel like with
this visual
palette they sometimes it does feel like
a michael mann movie sometimes it feels
like a chat's the hell's key movie
sometimes you know some of those shots
too where you're like swirling down like
those
giant staircases and stuff like it it
really feels big and
scopic in a way that's tangible and not
just like cg enhanced
yeah and i'll say too that i feel like
with the antagonists we're really gonna
be getting us
a clear sense of their perspective
you know like really get where they're
coming we're gonna examine everyone's
attitude in this situation
and i feel like there's gonna be some
great conversations to be had here
uh anyway guys falcon winter soldiers
keep a lookout for a reaction this week
on the channel check out that interview
if you haven't done so already subscribe
blah blah blah i've said a lot not much
sleep
hey let's do a page
lev doran flev continuing the tradition
where we're always shouting you out in a
marvel related video
you've been an incredible supporter he
made a request
ooh he was saying that for april on his
birthday
giving us his birthday that we should
shout him out then okay
we shout you out when we wanna shout
out who do you think you are trying to
tell us when to shout you out you're
lucky to get a shout out dare you i'm
going to shout you out on a video that
no one watches
now yeah we're happy to bury that bird
today we're gonna shout you out on a
private video
oh yeah i'll share the link with you and
you're gonna
know it's it's gonna be schroedinger's
workout forever
so much work into that shot
march right now so i'm still going to
check you out